foreign
Southland Museum and art gallery
my name's Gemma and I am the team leader
of operations here museums generally pet
collection items for protection and
preservation and storage and or
transport in our case here we are
preparing for our collection relocation
to our new tesbury storage facility in
this introductory video we'll be showing
you a range of picking methods this is
Lawrence a museum and collection
technician who will be giving you an
overview of the packing types we will be
filming hello everyone okay so this is a
pretty typical conservation box we use
in the museum for packing objects and
it's made from card and Bone but this
one has been specifically modified so
that we can easily take out the object
so the front will drop down
and then because the object is being put
into a tray we can then easily pull the
object out and we can live the whole
object by the tray again this is another
typical Museum box but this one is
slightly different in as much as we have
multiple objects and so we've put them
into trays where they stack one upon the
other which utilizes the space much
better and by removing each tray you can
see the next layer below
now this is a very unusual um and an
Innovative use of a different method
which is the bread tray and this idea is
do you be able to move larger objects
which we don't want to make a box for
um so that they can be easily
transported and when they get to their
new facility the object can be readily
removed and put on the Shelf okay this
is another example like the brick rate
where we bought something off the shelf
of Fish Creek this is very high quality
food grade so it's not going to be
damaging to talk to the objects and what
we do we replace objects particularly
Ceramics which can easily be broken we
put these in these fish crates and line
them with foam and then the objects are
frigid within that and very easy to
transport this is Rosemary my work
colleague and her specialty of textiles
and packing them and she's going to show
you this one particular dress on the
house you've gone about packing it
all right so the vast majority
Museum will be packed in acid free card
boxes items will be supported by
acid-free tissue paper this isn't a
permanent storage solution but these
items must go through our freezer to
make sure they're pest free when they
arrive at the new facility they've been
encased in polythene and all metal
bottoms have been covered so they're
safe for the process
over the next little while you will be
learning more about each packing method
the materials we use for them and why so
keep changing
foreign